-As you all know,
Juneteenth was yesterday.
And here to help us celebrate is
one of our writers, Jeff Wright!
-Happy Juneteenth, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, Jeff, I thought you were
gonna be here in person.
-Sorry I couldn't be there
in person, Seth.
But I will tell you all
some fun facts
and things you can also do
to celebrate Juneteenth.
Now, Juneteenth is a day
to remember, literally,
because Black people were freed,
but it took two more years
for white people to "remember"
to tell us that we were free.
So to celebrate, I say
take an extra two hours on break
every day.
I say take an extra two years
on an assignment.
I say, instead of showing up
to work, show up on video.
Isn't that right, Seth?
-It feels like a trick question.
-After all, I don't think
anyone minds if I'm on video
and you're in the studio
in your red sweater.
-Jeff, I'm not wearing a red s--
What are you talking about?
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
I think so, too.
-What? What is happening?
-I'm gonna be honest
with you, Seth.
This is a pre-taped recording.
You crazy if you think
I'm gonna work on Juneteenth.
[ Laughter ]
-Jeff Wright, everybody.